let's try to tie this up in a neat bow
we're almost there now what you can see
over here in part c
this is my best shot uh we're not in a
maths classroom so i had no ruler so
forgive my tangent it kind of like
wobbles a little bit but i gave it my
best go
what i've got here is a section of as
sebastian pointed out a section of y
equals tan 2x i haven't done all of it
because well it goes on forever so you
could never do all of it but the the
very valid question was asked like well
how much of it am i supposed to draw
like they didn't say draw it from here
to here so my suggestion would be let's
look at the question
nothing is explicitly stated so what is
implied right what part
of y equals 10 to x is needed to answer
the question now have a look part d is
kind of a key right which is like a bit
sneaky you're like i'm trying to answer
part c you need to know what's ahead
right
part d implies this situation down here
do you see it over here in fact i think
um
let me use this this is this little
triangle that the whole question
was working toward okay
so really based on part d
the only part of y equals 10 to x that i
need is enough so that i can work out
where this is going to go does that make
sense yeah
now just for the sake of completeness
you can see how much i've drawn um i've
got this asymptote that you guys told me
about but i haven't labeled it i wonder
if you can help me
ordinarily just regular old 10x has an
asymptote or the first one at x equals
what does anyone remember
it's pi on
pi on two right because you're dividing
tan is sine over cos and at pi on two
cos is zero so you can't divide by that
right but this is not 10x this is tan
uh i dropped it off this is tan two x
right we said it was twice as squashed
so this is not x equals pi on two it's x
equals pi on
four it's it's half of that because
everything is squashed in does that make
sense pi on two is now at pi on four
and that's why this pi on eight is here
uh you can see by the way because i was
sneaking i already knew this was coming
pioneer should be exactly halfway
between
naught
and pion4 so that gives me a rough sense
for the accuracy of my scale
were you going to be checked on that
probably not but the worse your diagram
is the harder it is to use it does that
make sense so it's in your interest to
make it as accurate as you can within
reason i didn't get a ruler out or
anything like that
all right so here's my sketch last
question
find the area of the triangle formed by
this tangent which i've drawn in black
and the coordinate axes so
the corner axes are here x and here y so
that's why i have this i'm going to
outline it here in black and it's a
right angle triangle right which is nice
for us you can see how part b kind of
leans into helping you get this answer
because you need a base and a height and
part b
told us what the base and the height
were
let's do the height first because that's
what we calculated first what is the
height of this triangle
have a look it's on the board
[Music]
okay let's think about this i did say it
was on the board i've got negative pi
over two plus one now just be super
careful with this right this is the
y-intercept so it's the i'm squishing is
the tv here it's the value down here but
just be watchful right you can even see
in my diagram that is a negative value
agreed cause it's down below the
x-axis right now we should make sense of
that because pi is about 3.14 that makes
pi on 2 about
1.57
so negative 1.57 plus 1.
that's still negative it's like negative
a half ish so that's where it is down
there but i don't need a negative i
actually just want the what we would
call the
absolute value right just the positive
part which is what happens if you switch
this around do you see that so i'm going
to label that as
a
height equals 1 minus
pi
did i didn't know all the way around
sorry pi on two minus one
that's a bit messy
pi on two minus one can you see it gives
me the same value but just the positive
version does that make sense
so there's the height uh boy that's
messy sorry it's really bothering me
there you go height equals point two
minus one and then i need the the base
which i guess would be this here
roughly where's that from
yeah it's from the x-intercept now
luckily for us this is already positive
because you can see it's over here on
the positive side okay so pi on eight
minus a quarter
that's the base
pi on eight take away
a quarter right so all i need to do is
go half base times height this is part d
area equals
half
base
and then here comes height pi on two
minus one
now strictly speaking at this point you
are done like they didn't say to
simplify the answer
but i think we should it's not difficult
to and it's a huge mess that's going to
become very neat actually if we work to
simplify this so can you help me out
what might be something you could do to
make this a little easier or neater to
write
any thoughts
have a look
working daniel
i expanded it yep completely and then
you end up with
i squared minus four plus four hold on
hold on slow down say that one more time
pi squared
uh pi squared minus four five plus four
[Music]
i did think there was some fractions
that should be there yeah very good yeah
pi minus two all squared on 32 yeah
okay so expanding is a way to get there
you can see hopefully some of you
recognize oh that's a perfect square
right
and that does look so much simpler it's
a big improvement on what's here i'm
going to suggest we can get that same
answer without expanding because
expanding is something which i often do
when i'm like i don't know what else to
do um it works if you can see the
factorization but i wonder if you can
see there's actually something here
we're slightly cheating because we
actually already know where we're headed
there's something here that can help you
see you do not need to expand quite so
quickly does anyone see it
hmm what do you reckon michael
converting to rainy's degrees is often a
useful thing for us particularly because
we're so used to thinking in degrees
however i'm going to suggest like going
back to here when you are in radian mode
versus being degree mode the real
difference is in what your calculator
ends up calculating right in fact the
format of this isn't going to be
dramatically simpler in degrees versus
radians and also don't forget this is
now an area right an area so in fact we
don't measure area in degrees we measure
rotational angle yeah so for that reason
i think radians is is fine here's my
suggestion have a look at our brackets
right
daniel's kind of helped us out because
we already can see we should oh this
thing is so dicey i'm not standing on
that side we can see we're going to end
up with this nice factorized thing so
have a look here particularly this one
right
can you see there's a factor you can
take out of this that will make it sort
of connect yeah our four is very close
it's actually
a quarter one over four right if i take
a quarter out of this i can't reckon i
can squeeze it in here
here comes a quarter and what you get
left with is this becomes pi on two
and this becomes minus one see that and
you're like oh i've got i've got two of
those
so this i can write as squared
i've got 1 over
i've got 1 over 8. this is pi on 2 minus
1 all squared i'm going to suggest
there's really just one step between
this
and this answer that daniel gave us by
expansion okay i'll let you guys work
that part out it's just a little bit of
algebra that you have to be careful with
so
this kind of question is pretty classic
it's the sort of application of
something you know how to do they didn't
even tell you to differentiate but you
know you need to to get a gradient of
this tangent and then the geometry that
comes to the right it's kind of like oh
it combines a lot of graphical and
algebraic skills that we want to assess
and that the hsc wants to assess that's
why you'll often see questions like this